you okay
yeah I'm all right is you crying don't
leave me alone you know I'm watching the
game no I'm not playing I told you they
was gonna lose I don't know why you
acting like this well how's you talking
about my business why is you talking
about my business but they damn bad
what's he points they cheated though
they cheated they cheated they cheated
we would have won they cheated you're
not hot with all that stuff on
yeah hey man why are you coming I told
you don't when they lose don't talk to
me for the rest of the week why is you
bothering me
dang well what about the wristbands you
act like they finna throw you in a game
to save the last couple of points first
would you leave me alone would you leave
me alone you don't even cry for me
for
22 years
yeah win lose a draw this one man